Well,
he gives zero fucks.
Your Ratha though,
drove,
rode to the Experia and the grass eaters,
they supposed to be grass eaters.
You ever have grass fed beef?
Do you buy grass fed beef?
No,
I buy it exclusively now.
It tastes better.
Where do you get at whole foods?
A lot of a organic grocery store.
Sprouts?
No,
you got to ask for it.
Yeah cause a lot of hope.
Even when I was in,
I was in whole foods and I,
I was asking for it and the butcher was actually trying to steer me towards um,
grass fed meat and he was like,
it's actually taste here or try to steer me towards corn fed meat.
And he's like,
it's actually tastier is more marbling.
I was like,
dude,
I know it.
I like,
I'd like to get that.
Please tell him like,
what are you saying?
Like you're telling me to eat something that's less healthy.
Like you're saying,
it's tastier.
I don't even agree.
I don't agree.
It's tastier.
It's a matter of choice.
And second of all,
it's been demonstrated that this shit is not that good for you.
Like when you're eating corn fed beef,
you're reading a sick animal.
The reason why they're so fat and Marbley it's their fucking ready to die.
Like it's,
it's like a fucking,
it's like Rob Ford.
It's like if you ate the mayor of Toronto,
like he'd be a corn fed cow looking at me like what the fuck is that guy still
alive?
Smoking crack and eating pussy there Charlie Sheen man,
if he came to America he would be the King of Florida.
Fuck if he just went to two.
If he just moved to America long enough where they trusted him and decided to
run for mayor of Florida,
he would be the King of Florida.
He made her and her brother,
I think he got a reality show already and then he was such a fuck up.
They cancelled it after like one episode but the canceled.
That's the reality show I want to watch.
The reality show was just the Internet.
You don't want an organized bullshit Beverly Hills housewives version of that
guy.
You want him doing impromptu live press conferences where he talks about a woman
accusing him of eating her pussy
and says,
I have plenty to eat at home.
Did you see that?
I wonder what his,
why you see that?
Yeah.
What his wife said about that.
That's almost an insult saying that she brings,
she probably said,
yeah,
ask him again.
I think we've got some leftovers here at the house.
It doesn't sound like you.
She has a huge pussy.
He said he has plenty to eat at home now that he's not eating enough of it.
You know,
I think that uh,
says I'm happily married and this is Toronto.
This isn't some podunk town.
This is the biggest fucking city and biggest city in Canada by far.
Yeah.
It's an enormous city.
Massive metropolitan city has and very international and when my favorite places
to perform on ours,
I love it.
Love Toronto.
Yeah.
I love this guy to listen this press conference.
I mean,
it's fucking fantastic work.
And he called me,
he goes out there,
he's got a fucking Football Jersey on.
He's a thousand pounds overweight.
Even Charlie Sheen was over eater who just talks,
they still
come in yesterday,
listen to all this,
um,
what's going on?
Why is that
the documents that was released?
There we go.
Uh,
unfortunately,
um,
it's unfortunate I have to take the legal action.
I don't appreciate people call Atlanta a prostitute and never had a prostitute
here.
I'm very happily married at home.
Um,
that this is very disturbing against wave.
unfortunately I have to take legal action against Isaac grants and McGeorge for
to stop lists and,
um,
mark Toohey I have to take legal action against the waiter that said I was doing
lines.
Your market that is celebrating the lives.
That is not true.
Um,
you know what?
It hurts my wife,
but in a,
they're calling a friend of mine,
a prostituted Atlanta is not a prostitute.
She's a friend and it makes me sick of people are saying this.
So unfortunately I have no other choice.
I'm the last one to take legal action.
I can't,
I can't put up with it anymore.
So I've named the names,
um,
litigation.
We'll be starting shortly.
I've had enough.
That's why I warned you guys yesterday.
Be careful what you wrote.
Okay,
so that's all I have to save for now.
And the next thing I want to call a mare Brittania,
it's in Hamilton and tell him that we're going to have to spank their little
tiger cats all in.
The last thing was um,
Olivia dawn back then it says that I wanted to eat her pussy.
They let him go on.
And I have never said that in my life tour.
I would never do that.
I'm happily married.
I've got more than enough to eat at home.
Unscripted nails,
every word of it.
And the best part about that video is after he leaves,
one of the reporters goes,
I fucking love that guy.
One of the report,
it says it.
It's like finally something's happening.
And he's naming names.
I mean,
the first thing you learn is politician is keep it vague.
Keep it general.
This guy's going like at Billy,
the waiter down there,
he said that I was doing lines and the
lines,
most likely you're doing lines,
especially if there's a video of you smoking crack,
right?
He admits to that.
Yes.
He admits to the video of him smoking crack.
He's beautiful.
He is a beautiful man.
Meanwhile,
by the way,
he does good.
These are good.
He has gone through the roof with him as the mayor.
It's not a bad man.
He's also a guy who came up through going to the projects,
helping out the working poor and you know,
being an inspiration.
I think he coaches a football team and the reason why he's an off his
favoribility rating is not that fucking low considering.
And it's because the poor people remember where this guy came from and he,
they know what he's done for that and they'll overlook who gives a shit.
Nobody really should give a shit the crack.
Yeah,
the rest of it.
Who Cares?
It's kind of funny that it's cracked too.
It's like you went for the most ghetto of ghetto drugs and he did it with a
bunch of black people and they got videos of him.
I mean,
does he not know what a fucking cell phone is where they're holding a cell phone
in front of him?
Look at Mike Tyson.
Shit's the best part where he said he wants to fight Mike Tyson.
He's like,
I'll kill Mike Tyson.
And he said,
Oh,
you haven't seen that and that's the best one.
I've seen that.
Oh my God,
I,
I've seen one where he challenged some guy too.
I'm an MMA fight.
Maybe that's it.
It challenged.
I've,
I've only watched like five seconds of it.
I was like,
this guy's crazy.
Jason Ellis,
he's a mayor.
Right.
Umay your,
I mean we had Marion Barry,
but that guy was like not like this.
He didn't have the dimensions that this guy had.
Well he also does not have the ability to own it.
Marion Barry lied about it all.
Like Marion Barry was on opening a and Anthony and I got to ask him some
questions and uh,
I was one yes in person,
as close as you are to me.
And I was like,
what about the crack thing when they caught you smoking crack?
Like I knew he only had like five minutes and I was like,
I am going to ask this like right away.
Like you can't like beat around the bush.
He's in and out.
He's doing a bunch of different reviews.
I go,
what was that about?
What was going on there?
He goes,
they,
they did not know whether or not what I had was crack.
Okay.
What they have is a video.
Me Smoking.
I go,
but what was it?
Was it crack?
Like wouldn't,
wouldn't answer.
It wouldn't say,
listen man.
Right.
I got a little crazy.
I fucked up.
I smoked a little crack.
That's what you should never said
I did.
Lines.
That's an outright lie.
It's an insult.
My friend is not a prostitute.
As soon as you have to see,
your friend is not a prostitute.
Nice man by name.
Oh yeah.
Kill that fucking guy.
I'm telling you a first degree murder.
Mike Tyson.
He is
walking around like this.
Fucking,
oh my God,
he's coked up.
Oh,
how come I haven't seen this?
Looks like
everyone in the room and he keeps on saying brother like brother
15 minutes
now because of this video,
I'm on the side of the people trying to get them out of office
because of that video.
I officially think he's out of control.
I didn't think he was out of control before.
I thought it was just being silly man.
Somebody from Toronto that I know,
it says actually he knows that this drug dealer that's friends with him and
that's that.
That's not calling in to the podcast on now.
I think they already have talked to drug dealers and I think this is like known
in Canada that like this is just ridiculous.
Problem is a fat guy.
Dom is dangerous.
Like thinking he can actually beat up Mike Tyson and it only needs this 15
minutes and I'll have him down.
Rip His eyes out like,
oh,
okay,
you're too stupid.
You're
delusional.
That's why you're so confident now.
I understand.
Yeah,
cause that's the dumbest Shit I've ever heard.
Politicians,
the mood,
like the decisions they make in their lives,
the fucking balls that they just cheating while in office when you think that
everything's being examined as cameras on you all the time and you're going to
fucking cheat and you think,
you know,
again,
I think they've always done it.
I think guys like,
like the,
the,
the Clinton types are the JFK types that,
you know,
have this like lust for it.
I think it's always been what they got away with.
It's always been a part of it.
Someone's always swept it under the rug and so they,
they've always kept going and like they like it so much they don't want to stop.
They liked the power of it,
but no one's ever been like,
no,
that's sanity.
Well the guy down in San Diego gave us a pretty good run.
He was right.
He was a grow lurcher light were dozens of Leche lecturer.
He was a latch.
Yeah.
That guy was,
uh,
he's,
he's been sued by a gang of them too.
Yeah.
There's that guy's going,
what's a sad about him is he didn't even get any pussy.
I think he was just grabbing acid.
So amateur,
that's eighth grade with seeing that guy say that he'd beat up Tyson.
He's like,
do you have any idea how fun that would fight that fight would be for Tyson?
Tyson would literally right now you can wake them up and tell him he has to
fight this guy.
It could be taken a nap and he would get in there and he'd be laughing the whole
time,
like laughing like all,
come on big guy.
You're going to kill me.
You're going to put my eyes out.
Were you going through it?
You to hold me down.
What's going to happen here?
You're going to rip my throat out.
Well,
to me,
I'm on from my profession and I said a ludicrous,
but I'm willing to engage you in this context if she so want.
If you thought [inaudible] have the dude chasing him around,
party hard,
like that's a great,
that's a great shirt.
Where can I buy that?
Please tell me it's for sale.
It is.
Andrew Wk is Rob Ford parties.
Andrew Wk is that guys by saying you're a millionaire before Christmas.
I'm buying one.
I'm going to buy one right now.
Party hard with blood pouring out of his nose.
A fucking love it.
It's on Andrew's official party store.
If you want to make some money,
promote the fight Tyson versus him.
No,
he got to give him cook first
and then you've got to have like 10 dudes outside the ring at all corners with
the,
the fucking defibrillators just ready to go.
Cause I know that guy's going to have a heart attack.
Right?
Like you see him pacing?
Like how does a fat guy that old do coke?
Like that's fucking dangerous
colds.
That Dude,
how old's Rob Ford?
I think he's four.
He looks old and 54 50 can remember being on a coke Jag and pacing like that and
saying shit like I'm a bad mother.
Felt like I remember being in that space.
Okay,
let me stop you.
You were 19 right?
Big Fuck right.
44 44 44 Jesus Christ.
It looks like shit.
Yeah,
I thought he was deep in his fifties so what happens to rob forward over the
next year is different.
Yeah,
most likely,
right?
But Canada is different when it comes to their ability to get people out of
office.
You can't just pull something out of office for conduct if they don't any
of the state laws,
if they don't like get in trouble,
steal money.
It was like a lot of things that you have to have done to get them out of
office.
So right now they're just sort of taking away his power.
They're just slowly but surely making him a puppet mayor.
They removing his power,
so that gets weird because then you sort of like crippling your own sort of
economy and you're,
you're crippling your own government.
Like I don't know if that's going to work.
Most people would quit,
but this guy's not good,
so I got to quit.
He'll never quit.
He's suing them.
He's going to sue them to keep his job,
but they should show that video and then have an expert come in and you're like
a teddy atlas and explain what would happen if Mike Tyson and him got into an
actual ring together.
Does this make sense or would you categorize a person that's 44 years old?
It looks like there's 60 that's clearly coked out of their mind.
It looks like they ate a beach ball.
D would you categorize that as delusional to the utmost?
Bring in Dr drew.
You'd have to just bring in a few fight experts,
just bringing Teddy Atlas and Jim Lampley and have them describe and then have
Mike Tyson and then tell him though,
theory athlete.
He said,
have him laugh and
okay.